رغم هجومه الدائم على دول الخليج واعلانه
المستمر موالاته للنظام الايراني لم يشعر
زعيم ميليشيا حزب الله حسن نصر الله
بالحرج وهو يطلب الدعم الماليه من دول
الخليج نصر الله هو الذي اقر في يوم ما
بانه يتلقى من ايران السلاحه والمال بما
يغنيه عن مصادر اخرى وهو نفسه الذي وصفت
تلك الاموال بالطاهره والشريفه اليوم وفي
خطاب جديد تحدث نصر الله عن المسانده
الخليجيه والسعوديه لمصر مقارنه بلبنان
داعيا في خطابه الحاضرين الى مراقبه
الاوضاع في مصر ومعتبرا ان الدراما مصر
معاهده السلام مع اسرائيل والتزامها لم
يحل دون اللجوءها الى الاقتراض من صندوق
النقد الدولي مصر من جهتها اعتبر تصريحات
نصر الله عبسيه وليست سوى محاوله استدعاء
البطوله زائفه وفقه ما قاله السفير احمد
ابو زيد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه المصريه
هذا ولقي مقطع حديث نصر الله او مقطع حديث
نصر الله لقد تفاعلا على وسائل التواصل
حيث سخره ودم وقع التواصل من حديثه وهو
الذي اعلن مرارا وتكرارا من نفس الكرسي
الذي يجلس عليه تبعيته لمرشد ايرانه
واليوم يطلب المساعده من دول الخليج التي
يهاجمها ويقف ضدها صور الوقت
في هذا المجال والديهم قدوه كبيره جدا على
مساعدتنا بمال طاهر نقي شريف بلا شوط
سياسيه
السطح
موازنه حزب الله
ومعاشاته ومصايفه واكله وشربه وسليحه
وصواريخه من الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران
طالما بايران في فلوس
يعني نحن في عندنا فلوس هل لبنان اهم
اوروبا من مصر
هل لبنان اهم للسعوديه من مصر
هل لبنان اهم
للخليج من مصر
الخليج
النتيجه
300 مليار
يحسبوا حالهم يلعبوا فوتبول
مع ضيوفنا من ابو ظبي السيد محمد علي
الحسيني الامين العام للمجلس الاسلامي
العربي ومعنا هنا كذلك في الاستوديو عطوان
زهره النائب السابق في البرلمان اللبناني
اهلا بكم
من ابو ظبي معك استاذ حسيني استاذ حسيني
سؤال بسيط ولكن مطروح بعد كم الجدل الذي
رافق هذا الخطاب وهذه الكلمه اللي حصل نصر
الله السؤال هو ما الذي يريده حسن نصر
الله من هذه التصريحات ومن هذه الدعوه
خاصه لدول الخليج
نعم مساء الخير عليكم جميعا وعلى ضيفي
الكريم
بدايه علينا ان نعرف بان كل كلمه ينطق بها
السيد نصر الله لا تاتي جزافا ولا تكون
بكلمه طبعا بطبيعه الحال غير مدروسه او
غير مخطط لها
انما هناك
ازمه واقعيه حقيقيه ليست في داخل التنظيم
البنيوي لحزب الله لان نحن نعتقد بان
المال الذي يدعي او الذي ياتي من ايران
ينقسم الى عده اقسام ويوزع بالترتيب الاتي
اولا بخصوص مهام الحزب
بعملياته ما يسمى بالعمليات الجهاديه
الخاصه به اي الامنيه والعسكريه وما شابه
ذلك هذه لها ميزانيه لا يمكن ان يكون فيها
اي ضرر لان حزب الله بالنسبه لي النظام في
ايران هو اهم من الحرس الثوري نفسه خاصه
في العمليات الميدانيه اذا لا ضرر ولا
ضرار بان هذا الموضوع مقطوع منه الامر
الثاني بان كل الاموال التي تاتي الى
تنظيم حزب الله باقسامه بوحداته ايضا لم
تتعرض الى اي مشكله او نقصان او الى اي
همم فعلا المشكله بهذا الاطار الامر
الثالث همم تنظيم حزب الله بافراده بالعكس
فانه مستفاده من ازمه الدولار واليوم اقل
عنصر في حزب الله يتقاضى ما يشابه تقريبا
500 الى 600 دولار وهذا لا يتقبل يتقاضاه
اكبر ضباط المؤسسه الامنيه على العسكريه
في لبنان وبالتالي قد استفاد حزب الله من
الازمه الامر الرابع البيئه الحاضنه لحزب
الله ايضا فهم ياتيهم من الاموال ما
يكفيهم الامر الخامس علماء حزب الله لهم
من المذاهب او من الحركات الاخرى لكن
المشكله الحقيقيه والواقعيه اليوم
ولماذا انطلق اا السيد نصر الله بهذا
الكلام بامرين اليوم اذا بحثنا وراينا نعم
نعم نرى بان الوحده الامنيه في حزب الله
وخاصه
مكافحه التجسس رفع الى مجلس شورى القرار
وبالتالي الى السيد نصر الله بان هناك عمل
امن كبير داخل البيئه الحاضنه والتابعه
لحزب الله باعتبار ان هناك عمليه تجميد
ونحن نسمع ونرى خلال كل اسبوع نرى بان
عميل هنا ومتعاون قد تم تجنيده داخل
البيئه او الوحدات الخاصه في حزب الله
تحديدا في الجنوب او في البقاع وهذا خطر
علينا كبير واخطر سلاح وهو
ناتج عن الازمه الماليه التي تعيشها هذه
البيئه فمن هنا كسر السيد نصر الله هذا
الحاجز وقال بانه هناك نحن نعاني من ازمه
ماليه ولكن هذه
الاجمل ماليه ولم يكن بسبب تصرفاته وسلوكه
انما اراد ان يصدر المشكله الى دول الخليج
دول الخليج وخاصه يعني مشكوره المملكه
العربيه السعوديه التي احتضنت خاصه
البيئه الشيعيه اقول فضلا عن اللبنانيين
نراهم يعملون في التوظيف
قولها همم
فقط
رؤيه حضرتك
مع ضيفه بان هذا الخطاب هو خطاب يحمل
رساله للداخل لبناني
ان لا يتحمل تبعات ما تسبب به من ازمات
الصبيه في لبنان نتيجه عزل لبنان عن محيطه
العربي وعن مجتمع الدولي واللي اتى نتيجه
الخيرات وفي حروب المنطقه واسرار على عدم
تحيد لبنان كما جاء في اعلان بعبدا في عام
2012 مع بدر الحرب في سوريا عن ازمات
المنطقه السيد حسن
في هذا الخطاب
اطلق مقارنه
لكي يقول للجمهوره ان خياراته هي الصحيحه
وان لبنان ليس حدقه عين لامريكا ولا
الخليج ولذلك نحن
خيارنا صحيح
اللي هو مجفن تماما للحقيقه ولا يمكن ان
يرفع عن نفسه مسؤوليه الانهيار الاقتصادي
لانه كلنا نعلم انه الفساد الاداري موجود
بكل العالم وخاصه في لبنان لكن لم يصل
بلبنان الى الانهيار الاقتصادي ولم يصل
الانهيار الى هذه المفاعيل الكارثيه الا
نتيجه انقطاع لبنان عن رئاسه العربيه
انت تقول بانه حسن نصر الله يطرح رساله
لداخل او يبعث رساله
الى الجانب الايراني هو
السبيل الصحيح الاختيار الصحيح طيب ولكن
هو كذلك يطرح فكره الازمه الاقتصاديه
الخانقه فكيف يستقيم الموضوع لماذا
الاقتصاديه
ويدلل على الازمات الاقتصاديه التي تعيش
حاليا مصر والاردن ماذا لو سالناه عن
مستوى الحياه في ايران في سوريا في اليمن
واخيرا في لبنان يعني في دول المحور الذي
يتنطح للدفاع عن مصالحه ويقاتل عنه في كل
مساحات العالم وليس العالم العربي فقط
يعني
ينزع عن نفسه المسؤوليه في الوقت الذي لا
يمكن له ان يتنكر لهذه المسؤوليه
يعني بيمرك تمريك انه انتبهي انه 100 200
300 مليار يعتبروا عم يلعبوا فوتبول يعني
وين شكرا قطر ما بعرف وين صارت شكرا قطر
اللي اعتمدوا من بعد عدوان تموز
والصداقه المفرطه خاصه انه دوله قطر معروف
انه تعتمد بالحوار مع نظام الايراني قادر
على التواصل مع النظام الايراني
شعبها دولي نفطيه
من الطراز الاول شعبه جوعان نتيجه انه كل
ما تستطيع ان تحصله عم تصرفه على
استراتيجيه العسكريه من اجل تعميم الثوره
والعدس بامن منطقه الشرق
الاوسطات تحمل شيئا من الاستهزاء بمن دعم
دول الخليج في الداخل اللبناني يعني ليقول
لهم بانه من دعمتوهم لم يقفوا همم الى
جانبنا همم هل اتفق مع هذا سيد حسيني لان
البعض كذلك تذكر بان همم
كانت هناك تصريحات لا تشجع على هذا
التقارب وكانت هناك حتى همم بضائع همم تم
الكشف عليها في حدود بعض الدول الخليجيه
التي تحمل فطيتها المخدرات والكبتاجون
ونتذكر هذه الملفات
ما رايك اولا في كلام ضيفي وهل
لك مع التعليق الاستاذ حسين فضل استاذ
نعم
السيد نصر الله يعلم علم اليقين بان دول
الخليج خاصه وبالاخص المملكه العربيه
السعوديه التي وقفت وما زالت تقف الى الى
جوال او الى جنب لبنان بالدعم المطلق وكل
الامكانات التي قدمتها المملكه
واعطت لبنان واليوم لا نرى قريه او بلده
في لبنان الا ولديها موظف او عامل او من
يعمل في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهي مع
ذلك
دعمت لبنان بكل ما يلزم ولكن كيف كان
الحسنه التي اعطتها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالنسبه للبنان وكيف رد لبنان
هذه السنه في التحريض عليه في التامر عليه
في ارسال ما يضرب الامن الاجتماعي والنسيج
والاجتماعي طلبت المملكه حتى الفواكه
والخضار
السيد حسين يقول لك ليس لبنان
وانا حزب الله
لا لا نحن نعتبر ما نحن نعتبر بان حتى
الموقف من الحكومه اللبنانيه عندما تعرضت
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كان موقف متاخر
خجول لاننا نعتبر نحن بان المسيطر على
لبنان وعلى القرار لبنان المعلوم من هو
اليوم من الذي ينطق باسم لبنان هو حزب
الله وهذا غير مخفي على الجميع لكن نرى ان
كل ما بدر من لبنان تجاه الاخوه العرب نعم
نعلم نحن لا نعمم ولكن هناك فئه واضحه وهي
لديها سيطره وانكامات هي التي حرضت ضد
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي التي ارسلت
مقاتلين هي التي حررت على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
هذا كله في ناحيه والناحيه الاخرى ماذا
تريد الدول الخليجيه او المملكه كما قال
معالي وزير الماليه ان ينتهي عهد الذي
تدفع به المملكه
دون شروط او دون مقابل وما هو المقابل
الذي تطلبه المملكه ان يكون في لبنان دوله
ومؤسسات ومحاسبه ان يكون هناك اصلاح حقيقي
واقعي حتى تدفع المملكه فلا يمكن ان تعود
المملكه لما كانت عليه من قبل ان تدفع
بالمليارات الدولارات ان تذهب الى هنا
وهناك الى الحواشي والى الفاسدين في
الدوله اللبنانيه ابدا المملكه لم تتخلى
عن وظيفتها وعن مساعدتها الاخويه للبنان
ولكن على لبنان ان يتحمل المسؤوليه ويقوم
بالاصلاحات ويقوم بفعلا بتحمل بان يكون
دوله حتى يعطى ما يستحق ولن يتاخر عنه
ولكن السيد نصر الله يعلم علم اليقين بانه
هو يريد ان يقول للداخل اللبناني بان الذي
لا يدعمه هم اهل العرب او اهل الخليج
تحديدا في الوقت الذي ايران تريد ان تمد
يدها ويعلم ايضا بان اول المبادرين واول
المساعدين الاخوات
صحيح وضحت نقطه حظرتك فقط لن نستغل كذلك
الوقت في تحدثت حضرتك عن انه وايد كلام
ضيفنا السيد رضوان بانه هذه الرساله هي
الرساله الاساسيه لدخل لبنان ولكن سايت
انطوانه داخل لبنان كيف يتلقف هكذا
تصريحات وهكذا خطاب
اهم علماء ضعف السيد حسن نصر الله وحزب
الله انه ذهب في الفتره الاخيره على
الخاطر والجمهوره تحديدا
انتبهي في هذا الحديث الاخير عندما خرج
ليقارن بين من طبع مع اسرائيل ومع من يطبع
من عبره كي يقول هذا الكلام الا ترسيم
الحدود البحريه اللي هو عمليا عمليا
اجراءات امنيه ثنائيه بين حزب الله
اسرائيل
بعدم الاستفزاز رقم كل الكلام الكبير من
جهه اسرائيلي مجاهد حزب الله وبالتالي هذا
الذي حفزه لطرح هذه المعادله من طبع ومن
لم يطبع من اقام السلام ومن لكم السلام
لبنان كله لا يريد السلام مع اسرائيل انك
اخر دوله عربيه وبالتالي هذا الهجس ليس
موجود لدى احد الا لدما ارتكب التطبيعه
عمليا ويكابر بانه هو المقاومه الوحيد
في البحر
همم
الضعف ان يحاول اقلاع جمهوره بشكل متكرر
اما المعارضه اللبنانيه والقوات اللبنانيه
التي انتمي اليها هي راس حربيتها فمعلوم
لدينا وواضح لدينا الموقف السعودي والموقف
الدولي بشكل عام ونحن نتفهمه نعم قال
السيد
ضيفك الكريم انه هناك من يهيمن على لبنان
ولبنان صاحب الموقف بعد رئاسه ميشيل العون
انا ذكرت اعلان بعبدا ايام الرئيس بشار
سليمان الذي تكلم عن سياسه النائب النفس
بعد ترخص من شارع العوامل الدوله
اللبنانيه وهو ملتحق بحزب الله وحليفه
اصبحت سياسه حزب الله هي المعاونه على
السياسه الخارجيه اللبنانيه واصبح مبررا
لاصدقاء لبنان العرب ان يتبراوا من اي
توظيفات فيه تستخدم ضدهم ضد امنهم ضد
استقرارهم وضد كل ما هو مصلحه عربيه
مشتركه نعم هذا ما حصل وهذا ما دفعنا الى
المعارضه الشرسه لحزب الله ولحلفائه ونحن
مستمرون في ذلك ونتفهم ان لا يقوم احد
بتمويل سلطه في لبنان قد يذهب غالبيه هذه
التمويل لتريح حزب الله وبيئته الحاضنه
وجعلهم يمعنون في العدائيه للدول العربيه
والمحيط العربي الذي هو محيط طبيعي
في البرنامج اللبناني والشكر كذلك لضيف من
ابو ظبي سيد محمد علي الحسيني الامين
العام للمجلس الاسلامي العربي شكرا لكم